martin biron michelle sy au jai alai
castonguay bonsoir
un petit mot sur tour de table sur
guettant barrette qui ne va pas donc
solliciter un troisième mandat hier avec
sa chef derrière une sortie qui a été
généralement décrite comme étant réussi
martin qu'en pensez vous oui bah c'est
vrai que c'est une sortie qui réussit
pas tombé en bas de ma chaise on s'en
doutait bien qu'il ne se représenterait
pas en 2022 il va nous manquer il fait
partie de ces politiciens qui avait pas
la langue de bois qui est assez coloré
assez sympathiques ou si ce sont eux qui
ai pas tout réussi mais au moins on
avait l'heure juste avec lui ayant aidé
de nombreux députés tous partis
confondus fiq avait des problèmes de
santé c'est quelqu'un de très généreux
très intelligent et comique michel
moi je vais toujours me souvenir de
notre vue que je fais que le docteur
barrette qu'un de ses seins les mâles y
venaient au micro ce qu'il avait dit
attristé quand ça allait bien il restait
de la vidéo il pouvait vous parlez
idéalement de philosophie medicare je
suis jamais fait une entrevue sur
la procréation assistée on avait fait du
thym dans l'émission pour la porte c'est
tellement bon
carnet de santé pas de la réforme de la
santé pas de ce qui se passe dans les
hôpitaux publics de santé en général ça
bonal absolument fascinant évidemment ça
venait avec le vol de 11 heures que vous
avez l'écrit mais on se change pas quand
on a les bons politiques oui avec
il avait un côté casse en même temps il
répondait aussi à une volonté de son
gouvernement et lui même à conférence de
presse avec beaucoup de candeur
d'ailleurs ça je l'aurais pas fait mais
j'ai pas le choix c'était une commande
d'en haut et parler notamment de la
position du commissaire à la santé ou la
procréation assistée qui devenait
payante le dont la gratuité pour une f1
doit je n'aurais pas dû faire ça en même
temps je peux pas le choix donc ce
serait beaucoup de candeur quand même
montré qu'ils n'étaient pas seuls à en
prendre ces décisions là c'est un
travail d'équipé gouvernement et d'une
partie du travail d'équipé diète avoir
été accomplis qui était pas uniquement
qui n'est pas uniquement de lui je pense
que l'assemblée halpern expertise en
général même dans l'opposition c'est un
assez bon vulgarisateur puis qu'ils
étaient capables de dans des bottes
d'amener le débat plus loin à se poser
pour la faire de tout le monde la
manière était parfois un peu quand on
rit mais il y avait une grande
connaissance du réseau de la santé c'est
pas pour rien que même à la cas
quelqu'un comme martin koskinen le chef
de cabinet de legault avait besoin de
consulter une fois de temps en temps
même si ça faisait pas la sphère de
dominique anglade parce qu'il a mis un
éclairage différent sur les débats en
santé ça ça vous manquiez l'assemblée
nationale oui on espère qu'ils vont
rester dans le dépôt éventuellement même
s'il n'est plus député parce que ça
reste quelqu'un intéressant à écouter la
pandémie a fait que je pense qu'il est
sorti des lignes partisanes beaucoup
plus l'autre at il déjà et tout dans des
lignes partie d'une autre chose mais on
se souvient qu'il ya des cadres de la
caq à l'époque mais bref et on voyait
qu'avec ses tweets entre autres il
voulait donner son grain de sel au débat
martine et avoir l'air plus positif le
quoi je pense qu'ils voulaient refaire
son image se se présenter différemment
il a trouvé ce très lourd le de traîner
sa réforme ont été mis les attentes et
où l'on s'en va et on l'a
et c'était difficile pour lui il voulait
redorer son image
il y avait aussi un lien proches alec en
parle avec martin koskinen qui est le
chef de cabinet de monsieur legault ce
sont des amis ils se connaissent bien
ils ont un cercle d'amis puis s'il se
rend compte des fois andorre la
politique et pendant la pandémie
monsieur barrette avait quand même pas
mal de contacts et il a mis l'épaule à
la roue le camp cité difficile comme
d'autres députés l'ont fait lé dans
leurs champs d'expertisé mais monsieur
barrette a été là il était prêt à servir
vous parlez de martin que skins est
intéressant parce qu'on va parler des
diseurs de la caq qu'on a célébré en fin
de semaine je vous fait entendre un
petit extrait de monsieur legault qui
bien sûr a dit à ses militants
la prochaine on en redemande
la population du québec leur confiance
on est qu
on a déjà ensemble fait beaucoup de
changements
mais on a encore beaucoup de changements
faire je penche
j'ai comme l'impression
qu'on va avoir besoin d'un autre monde
ça serait payable une salle du conte
de corse et c'était dans l'homme
alex commence avec vous on va parler des
10 à d'abord et de son nez là
quand même plus de parties ont réussi au
québec à s'imposer le parti québécois en
76 qui a été créée en 68 il ya la cat
qui dix ans après maintenant quand même
pas 6 et 5 1 au pouvoir quatre ans
pouvoir alors avec sur ce 10 ans et sur
là où il est rendu là
mais c'est un gros bouleversement dans
l'échiquier politique parce que la
fameuse troisième voie dont bien des
québécois ont rêvé je pense à mario
dumont patron à l'époque de la dq donc
une voix nationalistes mais qui ne soit
pas souverainiste
avait jamais réussi à s'imposer d'être
capable d'imposer sa au pouvoir
c'est quand même quelque chose donc ça
va bouleverser l'échiquier politique
c'est très difficile pour plusieurs
parties de retrouver leurs marques
depuis ce temps là je pense au parti
québécois entre autres mais même au
parti libéral où on se cherche un
courant nationaliste chez les
francophones le pour être capable de les
séduire un électorat qui a vraiment
déserté vers la caq donc ça va
complètement réaligner les planètes est
ce que c'est temporaire une élection ou
deux ce que ces permanences ont offert
aux biens mais c'est clair que ça au
delà du personnage que françois legault
a réussi donc amené au pouvoir lui même
ils ont ils la donnent une crédibilité
et une légitimité à un mouvement de fond
qui n'avait jamais pu s'imposer dans les
années précédentes ça c'est déjà en soi
une victoire skis moment pour seul
autrement dit on verra bien mais d'avoir
réussi à s'imposer comme troisième voie
c'est déjà quelque chose michel il a
réussi ils ont réussi à dépasser les
cette bataille qu'on voyait un éternel
entre le parti québécois et les libéraux
redevenir une union l'appui je serai pas
là le lien facile avec l'union nationale
mais redevenir une union parce que des
fédéralistes à la cac il ya des
nationalistes il ya des souverainistes
également donc ça il a réussi à faire ça
le réussir c'est ou c'était aussi dans
l'air du temps faut pas l'oublier le
parti québécois à cette époque-là s'est
mis à perdre des deux côtés il s'est mis
à perdre à sa droite à la perdre à sa
gauche à québec solidaire qui est un
gros joueur aussi date dans le système
sont si ça contribue et l'usure du
pouvoir des libéraux ont contribué mais
force est de constater que monsieur
legault au pouvoir donnent aux québécois
à la grande deux québécois insuffisante
québécois exactement ce qui va se
ressemblent le parti québécois qui ne
propose pas de référent dans un parti
québécois plus économique à l'avenir
dans la ville mais c'est de ça que ça
l'herbe semble être exactement dans le
mille de ce que bien des électeurs
québécois sur trois régions vous étiez
vous étiez là martin en fin de semaine
et j'imagine que l'humeur est assez
bonne quand on est au zénith dans les
sondages saison oui c'est cécile et les
gens étaient très heureux était content
c'était vraiment organiser le pour
pocket de problèmes même le cahier des
participants le c'est presque de la
tarte aux pommes qu'on leur servaient
les gens et puis il me domine dans les
sondages et monsieur legault est bien
cerner sa clientèle des débuts du mans
deuil et dis moi j'ai envie de gouverner
pour la majorité pour les québécois les
francophones et c'est ce qui fait sa
marque ça fonctionne bien et mes
collègues l'ont dit ils profitent aussi
de la faiblesse de ses adversaires ça
c'était le bouquet de fleurs envoyées
après pour les 10 ans maintenant
il ya des écueils et écouter la réponse
de monsieur julien de madame guilbaud au
maire sortant de québec qui a 14 pages
explique entre autres pourquoi il trouve
ce n'est pas une bonne dès le troisième
vient écouter ça pour vient après
je comprends que monsieur la bombe
est déçu des résultats de la dernière
élection et je comprends qu'il doit
faire un deuil aussi quatorze ans que
monsieur labeaume emmené d'excellents
projets pour la ville de québec qui
était dédiée à sa ville de québec est
aujourd'hui messe à peu à travers cette
lettre l'homme et c'est ce que shell un
peu un deuil à faire un peu un peu
d'amertume mais également on lui a remis
une médaille pour services rendus
maintenant il ya une nouvelle
administration qui d'ailleurs s'est fait
élire avec certaines propositions
notamment sur le tramway est donc on va
travailler avec monsieur marchand puis
effectivement je pense que c'est bien
qu'on puisse passer à autre chose
bon alors pas donné tous les extrêmes
autrement dit on dire au maire sortant
de québec merci mais non merci les
critiques sur le tunnel le troisième
bien on n'est pas capables les entendre
martin sait ce que ça donne comme
impression il ya deux jours à dire
là-dessus d'abord le caucus de québec et
monsieur la bombe ça fonctionnait pas et
je vous donne juste l'anecdote suivante
le tramway c'est réglé dans le bureau de
monsieur legault avec le ministre des
transports françois bonnardel pendant
que geneviève guilbeault quitte à la
représentante de québec la ministre
responsable de québec était à la période
de questions et ça marche pas du tout en
johnathan julien monsieur la bombe alors
visiblement ces deux-là lui ont remis la
monnaie de sa pièce pour ce qui est du
troisième lien je dirais que c'est dans
le narratif de la cac c'est le fils qui
retrousse et cités sont le sentais aussi
dans la salle ya un militant qui a pris
la parole qui dit l'environnement c'est
important pour moi le troisième mais
j'ai des doutes il y avait une mêlée de
presse après et en coulisse moi je suis
promené et député aussi trouve que ça
coûte cher le troisième bien il trouve
que l'échéancier loin alors on commence
à soulever a chuté en coulisses non
seulement nous serons sans voir avec le
troisième bien je pense que pour
monsieur legault le ya un drapeau qui se
lève sur ce c'est bien parce qu'alex et
ce n'est pas en niant toute forme de
critique ou d'expertisé vous comprenez
rien vous n'êtes pas de québec
taisez-vous qu'on va avancer le débat
non et j'ai trouvé que y aller d'une
personnalisation de ce débat là par
rapport à régis labeaume ça manquait
d'élégance ça manquait de hauteur
françois legault sa réaction était
correct et le t-bond il le dit c'est
juste la bombe sur un simple citoyen je
vais lire ça passe ça salit très je vais
lui répond mais geneviève qu'il vous
plaira tant julien honnêtement moi j'ai
lu la lettre de 14 pages ça ne sent pas
l'amertume c'est assez factuel ça est ce
que le maire veut se mettre du bon côté
de l'histoire le maire sortant
probablement est-ce qu'il arrose une
graine déjà bien implanté d'opposition
au troisième lien certainement ça ça
fait pas la faire à la 4 mai avait pas
beaucoup d'amertume ou deux policiers
qui étaient déçus de perdre ces
élections latin d'abord on n'écrit pas
une lettre de 14 pages la veille de
l'envoyer là bas et je pense que ça
faisait un petit bout qu'il l'avait
préparée alors moi j'ai trouvé que ça
manquait de hauteur et ça fait en sorte
qu'on essaie de faire dévier le débat
sur les personnalités qui s'y opposent
nle plutôt que d'y aller sur des faits
il y en a pas encore d'études y en a pas
encore de preuve que c'est une bonne
idée ce troisième n'est là n'est pas
beaucoup d'experts qu'ils l'approuvent
est ce qu'on fait en ce temps là bas on
dit que les ceux qui sortent on
mais maman donne il faudra au moins cela
ouais c'est ça mais ça fait plusieurs
fois qu'on dit ça mais je sais que manet
il faudra qu est un argumentaire des
études
un plaidoyer étoffé et non pas je sois
franprix
mais le débat en charge de base vous
vous déplacerez cela ses pulls et est ce
que c'est une bonne idée de faire un
troisième est ce que c'est que tu
écologique ou pour le débat ça 10
milliards de dollars 10 milliards de
dollars pour mémoire c'est assez pour
rénover toutes les écoles du québec au
grand compliquer en auraient besoin sur
cbc sait moins c'est plus que la
dernière c'était réseau de centrales
hydroélectriques
est ce que monsieur labeaume est venu
dire c'est que ce n'est là avec des
mesures simples qui coûtent pas cher
changer une voix de bart vendeurs de
points de suite pour pierre laporte va
faire la tête des ponts on peut
probablement avoir le même effet pour
une fraction et d'une fraction du coût
alors ce qu'ils pensent pas dans le
troisième mais maintenant ce qui va en
faire un enjeu électoral
c'est le ding à 6 milliards maintenant
alors qu'on apprend comment sécuriser ou
pas ces détails de ce que ça peut être
après way est ce que martin vous pensé
qu' on va changer de stratégie donc on
va c'est il m'a évidemment c'est sûr que
c'est ces circonscriptions il l'a promis
c'est pas le genre à mettre une croix
sur une première ses lecteurs elle c'est
pas du tout dans un style de monsieur
legault mais est-ce qu'il ya moyen de
l'aménager de chute de voir les choses
différemment c'est certain qu'il va
passer sa campagne électorale à défendre
ce projet là et et c'est le 10 milliards
de dollars c'est le plus gros projet le
plus gros investissement cas dans ses
cartons la cac et monsieur legault on en
parle dans aucun discours alors il doit
certainement trouver quelque chose qui
cloche ci se vendent pas de ce projet là
allait qu'est-ce que halo projet jeudi
mon avance est tellement forte que je
peux traverser la prochaine campagne
électorale avec ce projet là puis on
sera encore au pouvoir
le calcul est certainement imploser
mais martine a raison françois legault
et quelques uns de ses forces et ses
qualités sont au même endroit c'est
quelqu'un de très persévérant qui logent
pas facilement le morceau dans certains
changements comme son gréement voir
imposer c'est une bonne chose ils vont
pas facilement se laisser détourner de
son objectif le défaut par contre ce qui
est difficile quand on dit grosses
promesses comme celle là de les mettre
au rancart et de d'assumer les coûts
politiques qui viennent avec est ce que
dans un prochain mandat avec des études
environnementales quelque chose d'un peu
plus solide ils seront mis de côté je ne
le sais pas mais moi je les vois pas du
tout reculé avant les prochaines
élections ils pensent qu'ils sont
capables de passer à travers avec ce
projet là puis vont foncer à moins d'une
très grosse surprise ce sera une
décision peut-être plus
faisable plus facile à prendre dans un
deuxième mandat - michel conclusion
c'est plus facile d'abandonner une
promesse quand on vient d'être élu mais
sérieux c'est vraiment un boulet pendant
toute la campagne électorale à cause de
la fracture et ça il n'y a pas d'étude
qui va changer seul c'est lui qui a
disputé 13 milliards ou plus alors il ya
un problème avec ce très bien la
prochaine fois on part du congrès des
libéraux c'est fin novembre on aura le
temps merci beaucoup à vous trois bonne
soirée
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne i cirdi
oh